it's the same wedding the same
celebration no matter what table you
read you a guy you got something bro
Neffe this is where I'm sitting so if
you end up in the high teens you know
where to find me today will not suck hi
hello my god
I am Renzo I've achieved puberty and I'm
in a rock band I'm Walter and level
survey tributing I'm Francie Miller's
first nanny I can smell the toilets from
here that's how well we know the bride
and groom I'm Eloise I got dumped by
Francis brother the best man back there
at Table one oh no [ __ ] this is a great
table it's a great one you know it isn't
yeah not it we didn't think you'd be
coming you RSVP'd no and then yes an
RSVP card that you barbecue after two
years you break up with the over text
good luck with your future endeavors are
you firing me
Kien want Franzese mother crawls table
19 a table that should have known to
send regrets but not before sending
something nice off the registry but the
table that could disappear in the middle
of the wedding and no one would even
know this the table of people they don't
care about how are we doing back here
let's go what if you came here for a
different reason today what if you went
away with something better
do you ever have that kind of day wait
the things that come so easily to
everyone else just same so lusus know
yeah me neither
I come to you asking for Megan Anne's
hand in this dance and the rest of her
body
hello that head this is not gonna happen
so you could just stand awkwardly in
front of another table it was lovely
dancing you how did I not just get
kissed it happens more often than you
think
you are Romeo and Juliet and we all wish
you the same happy ending
I will give you $20 if you stand up
right now all right
what honey
Oh how long have you worked here